hello everybody markiplier here with
Mark Lars Monday mania mash male maxi
mmmm mmmmmm oh ok so anyway hello
everybody we're here but before we get
started I want to say I'm a few things
last week there was some concern that I
was being mean of at some of the letters
house gotten and I really I really am
sorry that it came off that way in I
wanted to apologize if it did because I
realized that I was trying to be more
entertaining than I was trying to show
that I actually cared for the letters
and I do care because when the camera
goes off I don't just throw these in a
pile I actually go through every single
letter and reread it I open the boxes I
organize things um just because it's not
done on camera doesn't mean it's not
done and I don't care because I really
do anyone who knows me and has been with
me for a while knows that I care about
this channel in the community that we're
building more than anything I've ever
done I i love you guys to death and i
want you to know that so i have to be
better you know i have to be better in
that regard so we're going to be
changing up a few things on how this
goes basically like i want to say that
it really felt bad for me that people
thought like I got emails sent to me
quite a few actually that people were
saying that I wasn't the person that
they thought I was and and that that is
the most hurtful because well I mean it
I didn't give any reason not to say that
so it's it's not their fault it's my
fault for not portraying that because
there's only a few times that i'm
actually on camera and i'm really doing
in when I'm uncensored for an hour
straight I can't I have to be more
careful about what I say and how I
portray myself because I do care and I
want you guys to know that I care
because this relationship between you
guys and me that's so important and
that's why I got to make sure that
that's always you know explicitly stated
in everything that I do so with that
said we're gonna change some things this
video is going to be about exactly an
hour long and in that I'm going to take
my time and open 45 minutes worth of
boxes like whatever I do in 45 minutes
that's what I get done and the last 15
minutes we'll be doing will be dedicated
to the letters because i don't think the
letters have been getting enough
attention
think that I just only care about the
pedestrians in the box which I don't I I
love them just the same but you know I
also care about the words that you guys
sent me so i'll be reading letters for
15 minutes and opening boxes for 45 and
i will be taking my time and taking it
slowly and making sure that i care or
show you guys just how much i care
because i really do oh and um those
someone else i was gonna say oh yeah i'm
in a different room if you if you guys
didn't notice I'm in I just moved I just
moved to a new apartment I'm no longer
living with my brother so if you if you
guys want to come over to my place and
party dresses right here you can find it
right here just look at this text right
here that magically appears in front of
my face come over and party bring a
pizza there'll be video games we'll hang
out and do other fun stuff so thanks
guys okay anyway so I'm gonna get this
show on the road sure okay I haven't
actually pre opened all these boxes but
this is an exceptionally sharp knife so
let's see what we can do here hahahaha
look at these mustache bandages
enchanted unicorn bandages and bacon
strip bandages that's better than both
of those previous ones combined that's
awesome these are cool and I I cut my
finger recently so that's not blood
that's just news board on it so I cut my
finger recently so i'm gonna use these
thank you so much that was from and i
haven't been reading the names and i
totally forgot about that that was from
there is no name cuz this was shipped
from amazon but either way you know who
you are thank you so much you are
awesome really all right throw that down
there throw that down there that's when
i saw it was fragile I'm actually kind
of concerned that it might because I
heard some crinkling in there I'm not
sure if that was just from
you know the the post office man
handling it during its transit but I
hope everything is in touch intact
because it does say that it's very
fragile so mmm very nice tissue paper
who's it from hang on it oh let's get
over this is from oh gosh so let's see
CL ski from Junction City I don't know
where that is but anyway thank you so
much hopefully there'll be something
inside ooh that's Purdy ooh look at this
guy's check that up you guys a little
pretty it's a pretty little box oh it's
a pretty box read markiplier I shall
dear mark here is a little package to
put a smile on your face as you do mine
I love your videos I'm the one who sent
the pinkie pie picture and rainbow
letter by the way there was more on back
of that letter I hope this helps you I
wish I could do more for you I will try
to send stuff when I can but a out
someday I bless you with lots of love
good health and lots of smiling scared
faces smiling scared faces Heather s so
thank you heather so much i got some
stickers here too let's see what is
actually in here oh I hope it's intact
oh good it is okay oh this isn't this
isn't that fragile so thankfully it's a
little watch um its ear buds cool little
earbuds a flashlight a now and later
candy a bunch of now later candy and
nerds I love nerds nerds are one of my
favorite crate I don't eat much candy
anymore I've been trying to be healthy
but you guys are gonna make me so bad
when I'm done with all this so thank you
guys truly thank you heather all right
put that over there with the bandages
and let's move on
all right isn't this the greatest job in
the world I just get to open presents
that's right every week I get brand new
prisons I mean a lot of ways I want to
say something else about that isn't
gonna happen um another concern last
week was that I was going to give away
stuff and um I misspoke in that I wasn't
gonna give away anything that was
explicitly meant for me you know and and
just in general I'm not I've decided I'm
not going to give away anything because
it's just uh unless you guys explicitly
say I'm waiting this round unless you
guys explicitly say that you want me to
give it away then i won't give it away
so everything is enemy will not go
anywhere else unless I unless I get too
much and I just feel like I need to
donate some things to charity which I
hope you guys won't mind about that and
by charity I mean I'll drop it off at
the local a charity driver or food bank
or whatever what have you like I've got
so many cheeses boxes that some of those
might go to the food bank so that's all
though anyway I can't seem to find where
I need to open this I didn't open
anything for beforehand because I wanted
to show it being opened on camera there
we go okay I think I got it there we go
haha ooh I actually haven't had this yet
it's the cheese at Scrabble jr. why is
it scrabbled jr. and not regular
scrabble I have no idea but I got the
scrabble jr. it's a smaller box too
alright so thank you for that another
one to add to my enormous cheese its
collection and we have a little mustache
necklace that's actually pretty cool
it's a little shimmery mustache necklace
there's a letter on the inside here whoa
nice Joker mask hi markiplier this is me
wearing a joker batman mask i'll be
sending you more cool stuff i'm probably
your youngest most devoted fan PS thanks
for the bday card happy birthday Liz
is happy 12th birthday liz ok so it's
not my birthday it's Lizzie's 12 so
thank you for that and also there's one
last thing a finger mustache of sorts
where you can place him with your finger
and hold them up like this oh I love the
foo Manchu but I have no idea how that
would be done oh it's a double finger
mustache how would that even work could
you hold it like this that's so cool
thank you sir haha one of them is called
the neighbor II know you can't see it
cuz I got a light shining right on my
face but thank you so much al is Thank
You Liz and there's also a fan art in
the bottom here oh man things are
packaged quite efficiently in here
there's a fan art of the slendy man with
a lethal be to the wharf sketch on their
go thank you so much grey get over there
and moving on this one is this one looks
like another one from amazon but it is
from jennifer kwok KW ok jennifer kwok i
hope i'm pronouncing that correctly i
have a feeling i'm not quote walk walk
Jennifer walk
you know a while ago I've noticed
something like the people people will
often think that I'm being mean when I'm
not especially like back when I first
played with a yamimash like his fans I
didn't know who I was thought I was
being mean to him when I wasn't because
that's just my rapport with people I
like to do that me if you see me and
Wade and Bob with people we goof around
we insult each other just because you
know we're friends and being friendly
and I got to remember that I can't do
that with everyone especially like
people who send me stuff and this is
really cool by the way it's all one Bob
pillow it's a spongebob pillow bong baba
oh I don't know what he ate but I'm
assuming he ate inflatable raft and it
just blew up inside them so do you do
look a little legs dangling there so
thank you for that and there's also a
letter in here get to it there's also an
envelope in here let me check what's in
the envelope first and then I'll read
the letter what we got that's me this is
um this is a picture of me when I first
got my t-shirt and I started selling it
this is the first picture I got so
that's me modeling that's my modeling
smile anyone want to take a screencap of
this no no no no okay let me read the
letter K oh no oh no no I got it dear
mark thank you for being such an awesome
person I've been a subscriber since
August 2012 the first time I watched one
of your videos my first thought was WOW
for a gamer geek guy he's pretty hot
after that I couldn't stop watching your
slender compilation video and decided to
go through your other videos and
couldn't stop strange thing is I'm not a
gamer I do play some games but not as
hardcore as others you're such a great
person you make me laugh and help others
through charity my little brother is
also a huge fan of yours but doesn't
have a youtube account so he technically
can't subscribe he is autistic so he has
some problems socializing ever since he
started watching your videos I feel like
he tries to talk more because he wants
to talk about you
videos that's great now on to the gifts
yay I know you already have a pink
mustache but I literally got it the day
before you got one in the mail since you
already wait was there was there a pink
mustache in there Oh since you already
had that I went out and got you a
spongebob pillow pet thing I hope you
enjoyed both and please keep them I do
not see a mustache I hope it didn't get
lost in mail this is from amazon right
so oh I do not see it i hope i'm not
overlooking it I do not I apologize for
that but maybe i'll i'll look later if i
find it i'll look later okay so i bought
them just for you so I would be sad if
you gave them away I will not before i
end this i also wanted to mention how
much I admire you you found something
you love and use it as both a job and a
way to help others i am in the last
semester of college and i'm still unsure
of what i want to do I hope I can be as
great as you please don't ever stop and
congrats on the two hundred and
eighty-five thousand subscribers just to
guess for the time you actually read
this you're pretty close I think we're
at 277 I'm not sure okay PS it would be
super duper awesome if you could send me
an autograph I can't but me reading this
on thing oh yeah there you go internet
autograph for you let's see thank you so
much for your spongebob pillow and your
leather and everything I wish you the
best in with your brother hopefully
he'll be a little better socializing I
don't I don't know how much my videos
can really help in that regard but I
appreciated all the same alright moving
on as you can see the hall is even
bigger than it has been before I'm
baddest they had told me to bring my car
around back just so that I could load it
all up from their gigantic cart like
seriously the cart that they gave me was
enormous and they actually accidentally
put some other people's mail in with
mine that I'm going to have to return
later because I've already looked
through everything beforehand to make
sure
oh excuse me so I gotta go I just ate
before this oh no that breakfast burrito
what not good oh my goodness there's
packing peanuts I've always wanted back
me okay let's see what's in here there's
a on there's an envelope get good
grammar their marklar all right there's
an envelope and that looks like it's
going to be a pain to open thank you so
much sarcasm got to put the tar queda
muy and there's something else in here
not sure what this is this gonna curse
me is this a bag of dog poop ooh what is
this this looks like it might curse me
oh no it's a dream catcher oh okay
that's really cool and a jar of
something that says hope on it I'm not
sure what that is it's some sort of
machon e metallic substance and we got a
dream catcher it says markiplier on it
smells interesting hmm but anyway thank
you i'm assuming you handmade this i
will open your envelope next and read
what is inside i'm pretty sure there
will be some sort of an explanation for
these gifts oh man this is supposed to
be a really sharp knife and they can't
even cut through your duct tape why did
you need doctor why okay all right all
night this is this is like a story I may
not be able to read all of this but I'll
read I'll gloss over the main points so
i will try to get it and then i'll read
it later i just can't read it all on
camera so dear markiplier i will begin
my letter with the legend of dream
catchers okay um you will understand
them at the end of the letters believe
that the Native American culture that
the air we sleep in is filled with good
and bad dreams as you can see dream
catchers are made in the way of a spider
web this is because it is legend that
good dreams pass through the center of
the dreamcatcher and/or of and continue
into the depths of our sleeping world
the bad dreams are caught in the
surrounding web branches and they perish
at the first light of the
in the past they were hung in teepees or
lodges or even directly over beds and
baby cradles all right I'm going to skip
over this because if you want to find
out more about dream catchers you can
find out on your own okay oh wait no
it's right here I first discovered you
while looking up amnesia reactions
online and at first I thought that
perhaps you were being scared for the
camera but as I continued on to your
other videos from your creation I found
out quite the opposite i found i enjoyed
your channel because you play horror
games and I love horror games I get so
involved in them that I feel I am really
inside the game and to be honest I enjoy
a good scare I also enjoy the fact that
you appreciate the hard work that the
creators place in their dark creations
you thoroughly enjoy games but the most
important part of your channel is your
support to cancer research on the
envelope you read do not read on camera
haha where where was that that was not
on the envelope that was not but um I
didn't read anything since Tim sorry I'm
really sorry about that it did not say
on the envelope anywhere do not read I
apologize for that I will I will okay
are moving on let's just move on thank
you for so much for the dreamcatcher I
didn't even cut the name I'll try to
keep what is in there Robin thank you so
much Robin so that I Pope okay
so moving on from that it said do not
read on camera and then it said I was
going to share personal stories so I
don't think I don't think I did anything
bad I'll by doing that so thank you so
much either way all right what have we
gotten next this is from I don't know
cool stuff calm all right Oh everyone
knows my one weakness I love ice cube
trays it's a medieval weapon ice cube
tray look there's a battle action a
shield and a sword and a crossbow and a
flail and a band axe oh my god this is
amazing and more this person knows my
one weakness guitar ice cube tray alien
spaceship ice cube tray oh my god
mustache bag clips these okay that's
awesome but there's no name from the
person who ordered it either way thank
you so much this is amazing I'm gonna
have so much cool ice I'm gonna beasts
get it cool eyes I'm gonna be so cool
I'm gonna be so damn frosty damn that's
cold ass honky that's what people gonna
say when I roll up to the mezzanine so
thank you so much for that that is
awesome I wish it was a name attached to
that some people order directly from
online and they ship it to my p.o box so
anyway moving on this one okay I'll
start picking random from the other side
over there what do we got here this is
from postal annex 5012 glad you're a fan
postal annex 5012
ooh this is from multiple people this is
it says oh it's from build a bear I
think love McKenna waiting in front of
the microphone love from McKenna
Brittany your biggest fan girls what do
we have in here this is a build-a-bear I
think whoo that's so cool look at him
you've got little camo pants and it all
he looks so adorable that is awesome
that's a custom painted em they must
have fainted that themselves that's
really cool thank you so much all right
anyway oh no oh no the little glasses
that came with it they broke oh no oh
that's a shame I'm so sorry that that
happened it must have broke during
shipping I don't know how looked like it
was been there pretty good but I'm sorry
about that i still love it just the same
all right smell my tummy uh what smell
my split assist smell my tummy it's
cotton candy scented it is actually it
smells like one of those up mad
scientists toy creations from when I was
a kid you know the ones like the
scientist get that made can do that's
what it smelled me reminds me of that
don't know why but it does all right
bilder where there's also a lot of foes
in there mark x height 15 inches weight
6 ounces for off white stuff with love
by brittany and mckenna so thank you so
much for that um there's a little bit
more in here they gave us free glitter
egg decorating kit so here you go happy
Easter sorry if it's late it's only a
little bit late so either way thank you
so much I appreciate it all right moving
on
let's make a random one some other
people time all right let's see what we
got here we got something from London
land something from London we are going
to see the first box well no I don't
think it's the first box from out of the
US but I don't think so no must have
been expensive ship by air overseas
thank you so much for your dedication to
get it to me what have we got mm-hmm
let's see dispatched notice ooh this is
just uh notice what's inside here ooh
ahh man it's just similar to the other
one it's a dead space mini plasma cutter
this might be similar to the other one
ever seen yep last week but either way
I'll take two I'll take your no problem
it is haha I love this thing I don't
have the other one here because I just
moved to here and I don't have all my
stuff but either way this is this is
similar to the 1i got last week and it
is like the coolest toy I've ever seen
in my life so don't worry about okay it
mmm oh it's not working at the moment
how do i how do I engage the battery I
don't know how but either way this is
ridiculously cool thank you so much i
love this little thing this is like i
love video game toys and i never really
get any so this is really cool thank you
so much for this um I don't see a note
in there I think that is it so thank you
so much for that that was from I don't
know because it doesn't have a name on
it and I didn't see a note inside of it
so whoever you are thank you so much
this side up from Stephen Williams man
people really like to take these down
make it our pain on me there we okay oh
of course we got cheez-its we got two
boxes of cheez-its pepper jack and
Italian for cheese but there is a letter
that says please read first let's give
it a little bit of a go our war they
sent me 20 bucks mommy twenty bucks I
don't deserve this all right let me
really read them let me read the note
let's see salutations mark Oh fancy I
will try to keep this brief as i'm sure
you're plenty busy my name is Steven
Williams and I have been a huge fan of
yours for going on eight months and I
can proudly say that you are a huge
source of inspiration for me I can't say
you've done anything as dramatic as
drastic as saving my life but as someone
who works part time to make ends meet oh
he spelled meet MEA t weekend okay all
right anyway coming home to watch a
couple of your videos is a highlight of
my diet a day I digress and closed in
this parcel are two boxes of teases for
cheese and pepper jack a video game for
either you or your personal your for
your personal pleasure or a giveaway and
a little figurine to go along with your
growing Mario collection I have also
enclosed a twenty-dollar bill which
should be donated to charity of your
choice definitely I was unable to
participate in the latest live stream
because of work which is unfortunate as
my grandfather died of Alzheimer's when
I was in Middle School and my
grandmother currently suffers from it to
the point that she no longer remembers
my mother Annie who has been said that
way I apologize for rambling so please
enjoy your gifts and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye well
thank you so much I will definitely make
sure that this gets donated to charity
whatever the next one
i will add twenty dollars to Steven who
sent me um in other besides achieves he
sent me a copy of Bulletstorm which I
have actually played before um given
that I played it and given that he gave
explicit permission to give it away I
might put this up in the giveaway game
collection that I've been doing but
thank you so much Steven and I'm sorry
about your grandfather but I'm we raised
a lot of money for Alzheimer research
and hopefully we'll come out with a
breakthrough volts arm is actually a
pretty fun game by the way it's made by
the same people that made um painkiller
know people can fly it's just a fun
shoot em up style game so anyway thank
you so much for that and there's one
more thing in here um oh this says Luigi
on it but oh there it is ok he's in the
bottom of the box i was about to say
like oh oh that's not good yeah he's
down here all right here we go there's a
little Luigi it's about time someone
recognized the true hero of the Mario
series Luigi he doesn't get enough
credit that yeah but anyway thank you so
much Steven and the Chi that's add my
collection of growing food stuff I
wanted to eat nothing but Jesus oh no
the little hope thing fell off of that
I'll try to repair that later of the
dreamcatcher thing ok so anyway there we
go I'll keep this in a safe place and I
will put that over there so let's get
that one
I picked it up I don't want the people
who saw me pick it up he like he got
mine Oh No what are you doing but you're
wrong and then you know just trying to
give everyone their fair shot that's see
we're coming up on 30 minutes so we got
15 more minutes of boxes and then we'll
go to letters all right sound fair sound
fair mark Blair you're so just and
awesome and amazing and so handsome and
so beautiful okay all right there's a
letter here dear markiplier first off I
know my handwriting is terrible so don't
make fun of it must resist urge to make
okay hi mark I'm Chris soul I'm writing
to you because of how awesome you are
and how much you growing you'll soon be
just as good as beauty pie or
chuggaaconroy I can't wait to see what
you will start calling your subscribers
nothing huh I I don't have any reason to
call my subscribers anything you guys
can call yourself something some people
have agreed on market flights I don't
really care i just call you the fans and
whatever i love every video gamer you
play from unfair mario to em LPS CP but
never call Pinkie Pie fat yes i'm a
brony and proud of it I were a My Little
Pony satchel oh I wore my little pony
satchel to school with derpy on it there
was a pony named derpy I know you're not
a brownie but the gift I sent you is
worth more to me than life itself wow it
a My Little Pony figure of one of the
main six her name is rarity please take
care of her continue on back oh okay she
was first My Little Pony figure I ever
gotten and it will mean a lot to me if
you keep her not trying to groan if I
brownie if I you but this is just a gift
from the brony community to you letting
you know we support you all the way plus
my dream to be a brony musician
roni musician what is that is soon gonna
start all I ask is where I start is for
your support all the way please let the
world know that I Chris soul is going to
be a music legend mmm am I only want to
be noticed by you I also want to be a
video gamer like you but that's still to
be decided all right so i may join you
in videos please markiplier never forget
me the fans the friends you make the
people you me let on your adventure to
being the greatest LP ER on youtube I
got your back hundred percent and never
forget that love from the brony
community Chris soul thank you so much
Chris and I'm sorry I had trouble
reading it but I'm not gonna make fun of
it but that's still the same so good
luck to you and I don't know what a
brownie musician is but whatever it is
good luck to you here's the special
figurine this is in a really nice box so
I know how much this means to you so I
will cherish this until the day I die
and I I actually I actually really do
appreciate the fact that people
understand that I'm it's a million boxes
in a box his boxes within boxes ah
another box okay all right those getting
does getting ridiculous there's now
we're now up to four boxes okay there's
another box it's another box in there I
won't make fun of you for your
handwriting but I'll make fun of you for
your box choices there's another boxing
girl could be paired this okay okay
we're good okay so this is well this is
um I don't know which pony way which
pony was this this was this was not
derpy this was
rarity her name is rarity this is rarity
so I will cherish this till the day I
die I'll put this up in my hair not one
ha it fell I thought sorry ok I will put
this somewhere safe and I will make sure
that it stays safe so thank you so much
good luck on your venture and I hope
everything works out for you in the
future now let's move on big one I wanna
see what's in the big one I know all of
you were like watching the big one i
watch thank you everything's falling all
over the place all right I gotta stand
up for this one so bear with me for a
second I bet if it's if it's more boxes
within boxes I'm gonna be so upset
because it's pretty light this thing is
pretty light pants print shipping costs
just to make sure that I waste time on
camera oh no bubble wrap know what it
really is is just as awesome it's a
giant finger oh look at this thing this
is awesome get open you bastard okay
check this out guys this is amazing this
is ogre alright i'm back sorry i had a
little bit of an audio driver crash or
something but either way we got a giant
foam finger which i'm going to be able
to pull out every time I end a video and
be like I will see you in the next video
haha this is like ridiculously cool so
big is so
and I don't know what um M state Montana
State don't Montana State go I don't
follow sports especially collegiate
sports so I have no idea what school is
from but go m state go m state the only
I'm state i know of his michigan state
but they're green so oh I guess michigan
state recently changed their colors so
go michigan state go michigan state yeah
okay all right over them next I
apologize I apologize for nothing all
right about 10 minutes left we've got 10
minutes left before we're going to
switch off two letters here so I'm
hoping I don't have any more little bit
of computer tribbles Heba douche and
Herbert all right I'll write her wrong
all right what do we have here this is
from Caroline a hippel Carolina hipple
and she sent me what looks to be a
cookie tin oh look at the little cookie
tin what's inside a bomb no really
awesome looking chocolate chocolate 30
pieces and there's a note covered in
chocolate right here but i will try to
decipher it in one moment got crumbs
ever okay i know the designs look weird
but the chocolates are so small that
that i can't fit the whole object i was
trying to draw leaving them blank just
didn't seem right to me these are how
it's supposed to look amaretto 10 pieces
which have there are specific symbols
it's hard for you to see but to each one
there's specific symbols peanut butter
and coconut enjoy Caroline a hip pitbull
on my last name the e is silent and the
eye makes a short sound
yeah I see that you're not good with
names who he's a little guide I put the
same thing at the end of the letter
there was a letter oh there it is ok
that almost hit away from me all right
whoo that is elegant look at that that
is really really elegant thank you so
much for that that's Chinese I believe
there's a long letter in here fair
warning please don't make fun of the
envelope I like it and it was the only
thing I had around at the time you don't
have to read my letter on air to save
some time just acknowledge it and move
on thank you so much all right I won't
make fun of it I was actually really
happy with this so i will read this
later and you said it was quite long so
i will read this later and i appreciate
just same Caroline a hipple bleh hi play
Caroline a high play that's how you say
it wrong how saying it right the first
time I think so thank you so much for
that I will enjoy these chocolates on my
hair ode to 800 pounds OOP thank you put
that down there just got a little more
Oh mark of our number one oh that was
markiplier state the M stands for
markiplier Markab our state go mark of
our shape yeah learn to be a youtuber ok
bottom just to kind of vary it up a
little bit give everyone a chance from
zack larson zack larson sends this with
lots of love lots of love from zack
larson all right what do we go whoo cool
oh let her but cool it's a um it's an
army a water backpack I wanted one of
these I actually wanted one of these
because I i just bought my bite a new
bike and I like to go biking and it says
the weather is finally picking up so
this will be great for longer rides so
thank you so much this is gonna be
awesome and this was an expensive gift
this says it was 70 bucks so really
thank you so much for this let me read
your letter
here oh haha it's a little patch I can
hire not or actually it's a velcro patch
oh then I can put on the thing fruit
says like a bauss alright this is a
letter already then if you say so hum
dear mark i would like to start by
saying you are awesome thanks I always
watch your videos after work or when I
get off duty whenever I feel stressed or
down i watch your videos and they really
help to lift my spirits I love the drunk
minecraft videos with Bob and Wade I
thought you could use a little more hua
while drinking so I got you this
camelback hydration system with a custom
name tape with your naming said my name
on it did I didn't even notice that look
it says markiplier on it that is so cool
I I totally overlooked that let's see um
be sure to wash it out regularly after
each use keep on making awesome videos
your fan private Zack Larson so I have
fans in the army I've never imagined
that thank you my dad was a 23-year army
guys so I'm really happy about that well
he may not be in the army he may be a
Marines I'm not sure um but either way
congratulations and thank you so much
for helping out um we always like to
support soldier my dad my dad had this
philosophy that everyone should join the
army to serve their country but I
disagreed with him on that but I'm still
really happy that a lot of people
dedicate themselves to that's where our
lives even though I personally I think
war is wrong but this I you got to
support the soldiers you can be against
war because that's just the government
leaders point telling younger people to
fight when they don't want to do it
themselves so you support the soldiers
and hate war that's what you gotta do so
thank you so much all right Boop
thank you get we got time for two more
problem so let's get this long one here
didn't expect me to pull this one out of
nowhere oh look look all right yea I'm
guessing Marines cuz of the hua that's
just my guess whoa dude whoa dude I was
grabbing by the wrong end oh my god
there's everything is just falling apart
in there I think there are some letters
I'm gonna get to in just a sec of it
whoa look at this thing and it's this is
actually that actually a block of metal
hahahahahahaha someone made me a duct
tape and metal katana it's not sharp at
all which is good cuz I would kill
myself if this was really sharp but
that's so cool they made their own um I
think cardboard and duct tape sheath and
just like that's really cool just this
action do anything for anybody is that
is that is that doing anything out Gator
enough silliness that's really cool
thank you so much now let me look for on
the letters that are a part of it oh boy
there's a lot of papers here I don't
think wait a minute oh there it is okay
these papers are nothing this is the
letter okay mark and a banana that a
banana nana anyway let's see here um
here is a crappy drawing hey you guys
can oh yeah I didn't say that it's not
me sick this is a crappy drunk no that's
that's literally what it says on the
page that here is a crappy drug that's
not me going well this I've gotten so
much better fan art danette no all right
dear mark unto you I give my first blade
it has held me slay many demons with its
aid train with it well and you
to may become a legendary samurai all
jokes aside oh I have been a fan of
yours for a little over a year I also AM
a gameplay youtuber and I wish someday I
could at least be halfway as awesome as
you are your charity work is great in
your videos are hilarious I'm in school
for game design when I eventually do
make a game I make one that's basically
you with a pink mustache cheez-it box
hat and a rubber chicken in one hand
sincerely Bryce Stelly gurren x12 rubber
chicken did I ever make that reference
i'm not exactly sure but either way
thank you so much and if you do make a
game send it my way I'll tell you I'll
give it a look at it I'm always happy to
support indie game developers especially
ones that are fans of mine so thank you
gonna put my picture creepily in there
I'm me in the main character I know your
tricks I know your tricks okay one more
box and then we'll get two letters tiger
by so if the hollers let him go eeny
meeny miny moe my mother's home let's
give this one yeah we got what do we got
what we got oh yeah we got here huh
what's this well it's a box that's what
it is open here alrighty then slice that
alone there your little slice and action
air like that and we are good to go to
mark put that blade down over there so i
don't kill myself to mark handmade with
love chibi Sayuri mark I'm glad you
liked your necklace seeing you unwrap it
was worth the hours it took to make you
gave me a brilliant idea of what to send
you next I hope you like them too I sent
you a bomb and anthrax it if you know
anyone that might like my work you send
them my way WWE etsy com shop / eb
arrive
that's here you can you can't really
read it because if it gets too close to
that yeah the light but yeah it's kind
of their chibi Sayuri hope I catch your
live stream this month see you in your
next video bye bye love chibi suddenly
so your eye I'm not sure so what did she
make this time it is a bomb it's a bomb
King it's the King from mario 64 it's
the bomb king who had a mustache and now
he has a pink mustache that is so cool
look at that as well done thank you so
much for that but there's one more in
here let's take a look whoa oh that is
creepy no offense that's creepy just
look at the way it's just it's got a
mustache to you can't see you click it
just kind of stairs at ya na moving
anyway yeah that is really cool thank
you so much for that that is well it's
really creepy but it's still awesome so
thank you thank you for that alright and
that will just about do it for the boxes
which means that we are going to be
moving on to letters we're gonna do 15
minutes of letters starting now I'm just
gonna grab a few there's also big
envelopes that you know I could open
that I want to try to get like letters
letters
that one that one that one from one for
Canada do that one and that starters if
I get through all these I'll move on to
more ow ah ow I hurt all right I'm fine
I'm tough I can handle it my handy-dandy
letter opener wrong come on okay we got
ooh ooh hey megaman battle network
someone sent me the the game boy advance
I've actually played this i played
through all of it I loved it to death I
love Megaman games so thank you for that
that looks like well-worn version of it
all right hello mark my name is Aladdin
Bullock I am from Chicago if in her
illinois and i love your videos you are
so freaking funny i loved your unfair
mario game play I knew it was painful
but it was funny to me and my friend I
was hoping that we can be friends please
if you can send me an email it's but I
won't read this online or add me on
Facebook I would love to do a video with
you and yamimash because I don't have a
single video on my youtube channel I
know it's sad but if you if you're gay
Mike you could help me out my youtube
name is Jason red heart 527 I know that
you may not be able to help me out but
just keep an open mind about it okay and
please read my letter on your next mail
time video yeah you should probably set
that like before like please read this
okay just saying I'd really be grateful
to you if you did you always brighten up
my day mark keep doing what you love and
entertain us I look forward to your
newest videos that you will keep making
for us and here is a gift from me it's
my childhood game megaman battle network
i love Megaman and i hope you will like
it too i do i've played it i love it
well thank you Aladdin so much for the
game I might give it away i'm not sure
but i will cherish this because you did
not say to give it away so i will not
give it away that's what I'll do alright
so that's one letter down thank you so
much and you guys can see like how much
time this takes me to go through all
these before like last week it literally
took me two days and I think about 10
hours to go through all of the letters
and I just want you guys to know that if
you send me something I'm gonna read it
like just because I don't respond to it
or read it on air does not mean that it
got ignored everything that I've gotten
has been opened its really hard and
takes a lot of time but you guys are
worth it ok so this is from mark YouTube
no that's this market rubrics a little
bit of fan art of in SCP containment
breach all right mark hey Mark I've been
watching your videos for a long time
that the highlight of my day next thing
you know you'll have 1 million
subscribers from slender SCP amnesia
gmod horror map you're awesome and I'm
glad I subscribe to you from John miss
Kavanagh on hello thank you so much John
I'll call you just John cuz the rest
your name I would never be able to
pronounce but thank you so much that is
awesome and you are awesome that's all I
have to tell you about that OOP all
right this one's a particularly thick
envelope to know what I mean okay looks
like there's a lot of stuff in here so
this may take a bit to get through all
right what have we got let's see there's
quite a lot of stuff there's another
okay it's another series of the slender
pages Falls I don't need to go through
all this cuz i'm imagining yeah leave me
alone it's it's all of the cylinder
pages no no no no so thank you for that
I've gotten quite a few copies of this
um see
ma
600 re GV grv ie I don't even know what
that letter is grave but I dust live in
for the world it's on I if you could
make sense of that like the top part I
have no idea what that says but but I
just live in for the world it's on is
what the rest says and there's a little
drawing I'm not sure what that says but
thank you nonetheless I would I really I
cannot read that like I'm usually good
about that but I can't there's slender
mark and then there's another letter
here ah my sister drew a picture for you
to she's tried drawing you oh here we go
hi mark my youtube name is 101 is ist er
s 101 I sisters and I discovered you
through slender the first video that i
ever saw from you was slender
claustrophobia complete with mushroom
trip mode that was a fun one I could not
stop laughing my other sister fell in
love with you through cry of fear one of
my favorite play through that you've
done all I can say is that you saved my
life thank you for so much for reading
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye no I'm not leaving no go
away so thank you so much for that and I
read your YouTube channel so everyone
can check them out oh right thank you so
much for all the slender pictures OOP
and now we're moving on to one from
Canada from Canada let's check it out
whoop yeah come on sorry i don't have my
letter opener with me so it's a little
harder to open these oh right what we
got here oops
uh-oh did that rip oh oh no oh it didn't
help me okay Jeff the killer as a pony I
think I'm not sure Jeff the killer is
the pony art to mark apply your vids are
awesome y'all make me smile laugh and
get scared thank you from Marin Merinda
Mirinda pronounced ma Rinda from Mirinda
thank you so much from Canada that's a
lotta that's a lot of stamps you put on
that marinda hanes thank you so much
buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy blood up
ok so now oops hey Wow hey you got three
more letters in the pile if we can get
through this in the next five minutes
and we'll be able to move on if not no
we got more time than that ya know about
seven minutes so we got seven minutes we
could probably get a few more out
alright let's see here um dear mark mark
by our awesomeness of our time I love
what you do and I really get a kick out
of every video that you do i find myself
laughing every time i watch your videos
i think it's really cool that you're
building an audience for cause greater
than yourself it's nice to know there is
someone out there still trying to better
others around themselves instead of just
looking too good looking to look good
for others i really hope that you get
much more in the next live stream that
you host should you do it again I do it
every month so stick around my cousin is
also suffering from cancer but she is
doing really well and keeping your head
up amongst all the fear that may come
with such an ailment I am attempting to
a similar thing with my channel trying
to provide in a positive example for
people who use the internet as I
frequently see that people hate each
other for really dumb things that in
reality we should actually respect to
each other for my view is that I can
show views young and old that video
games can also be Anna turn all turn
ative to destructive habits such as
drugs gambling and other destructive
habits while trying to provide the most
positive example I can for others while
encouraging them to do the same if you
could take a look at my channel or give
us
shoutout to my channel at mr. dragon
rider 2012 or even better if we could
work together on a collab or something
you can message me on youtube or send me
an email at I think that would be really
great I have been really struggling to
get my channel noticed by people even by
those I know in person I'd also like to
thank you for being an inspiration to
not only me but possibly thousands of
others your faithful fan Jordan Brunner
mr. dragon rider 2012 AKA Zia Zia Zia
jacks zuzia GAX X I AGA X so thank you
so much for your letter good luck with
your channel hopefully this gives you a
little bit of a boost their I'm not sure
how much it'll make a difference but
thank you so much for your support and I
hope your sister gets better so thank
you so much for that letter you you it's
amazing like when I go through all of
the letters and like over the weeks that
I've been doing this when I go through
all the letters it's just amazing how
many people have have very similar
stories where they have loved ones in
situations and what I've always wanted
to do is I wanted to not only do this
for ourselves but the other important
thing is to spread the word about it
like inspire other people to do the same
inspire other people to take action and
do charity live streams themselves or
organize charity events or if you can't
then just go down to a local soup
kitchen or something there's all sorts
of stuff where you can volunteer locally
I'm you just have to find it there's so
much that you can do to help out so
thank you for doing that all right what
do we got here dear markiplier i just
recently became a fan because my friend
told me about some of your videos thank
you for your friend and thank you for
you one of the best ways that we can
grow this channel is word of mouth so
simply telling friends about it is great
way to doing it so um and that I should
watch them and now you're one of my
favorite youtubers smiley face you're
really funny and awesome which is of
course awesome and I like the games you
play because they look really fun and
stuff also I wanted to draw you a
picture but I couldn't think of what to
draw so my friend came up with what it
should be but I drew it so I'm really
glad I
found out about you and I can't wait for
upcoming videos from cecilia let's see
the drawing is it up to my standards ooh
nice whoo that Hilah that night late
really helps oh he saw me that's my
slicker oh he saw me can't even talk I
don't even know but either way thank you
so much for the drawing thank you for
the letter and thank you for becoming a
recent fan we've been gaining a lot of
followers really quickly lately and I'm
so glad that so many people are thinking
that my channel is worthy enough to
subscribe to so thank you for that oh
right what have we got here it's a
letter with Slenderman on the back and
it's actually pink on the front I'll try
to block it pink pink mustache I think
there's pink letter inside it's pretty
much berry pink well people think oh
it's a living beyond breast cancer or
now it's a Susan G Komen a letter with
about lots of pink ribbons on the inside
so let's give this a try hey area mark
is awesome thank you and dear a
markiplier my name is Risa rhe gah it's
okay if you pronounce my name wrong that
happens a lot I'm new to your videos but
I've watched a whole lot of them I love
drunk minecraft and watching you play
slender hopefully sometime soon I can
get a minecraft and I would totes mix
groats play on zombie mold server
everyone should and uh anyway keep up
with the good work and I love your
videos lisa ay ay ka Flame Princess 330
1000 PSI love adventure time and on the
back of the envelope slender man faces
glow in the dark oh I was wondering what
that was and here's a little picture of
me and her together in adventure type
style so thank you so much for that it's
also covered with pink mustaches I think
that will just about do it for this a
Monday
alemania markiplier Monday man Nick miss
snail okay so thank you all so much um
if I didn't get to yours don't worry it
will be opened by me off-camera it just
won't be read on camera I will get
through everything I'm at some other
point in the future so thank you all for
everything that you have sent a thank
you guys so much I just want to make it
very clear how much I appreciate and how
lucky I am that I have such a great fan
base that will send me so much stuff
that I literally can't get through it in
an hour this is truly an honor it's
amazing um and I don't deserve this kind
of you know respect your admiration I
really don't but I want you guys to know
that I am eternally grateful for what
you guys have done I really don't want
you to think that I'm in any way mean
and i hope you like this new format
where I'm not rushing through anything
I'm very careful to read everything that
we've gotten if you do like it let me
know in the comments below I read oh
just about every comment in the last one
that's why I knew very closely i replied
to quite a few in the last 12 I am
reading what you guys are writing in
these videos so if you have something
that you want to say to me they're right
in the comments below but other than
that thank you so much for watching this
has been markiplier male number four so
thank you all so much for watching just
stay tuned for next time remember the
address to send me mail is in the
description below you can click on it
down there or down there i think it is
down right right there so thank you all
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye